ONE G.O.P. MEMBER OF THE PANEL
IS ALREADY OFF THE RESERVATION.
HERE'S CORRESPONDED
DOUG McKELWAY.
>> WE LOOKED AT IT THOROUGHLY.
WE INTERVIEWED NEARLY EVERYBODY
AND WE DIDN'T FIND ANY COLLUSION
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> AFTER 14 MONTHS OF INTERVIEWS
AND REVIEWING INTELLIGENCE,
REPUBLICANS ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCED
THEIR WORK IS DONE WITH A
FINDING OF NO RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
SENATE DEMOCRATS WERE SURPRISED
BY THE RELEASE, THEY LAMBASTED
THE AUTHORS.
>> CHAIRMAN NUNES AND
REPRESENTATIVE CONAWAY CUT OFF
THE INVESTIGATION, BURIED THEIR
HEADS IN THE SAND AND WROTE A
REPORT THAT CONTRADICTS 17
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND AN
INDICTMENT FROM SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER SHOWS WHERE THEIR
LOYALTIES LIE.
>> DEMOCRATS -- REPUBLICAN SAID
THERE WAS A RUSSIAN ATTEMPT.
>> THERE WAS EFFORTS TO TRY TO
HURT HILLARY AND HELP TRUMP.
>> HE ADDED A STICK RELATION.
I THINK THERE WAS THE OPPOSITE.
>> WHILE THE PRESIDENT CHEERED
THE FINDINGS, -- >> WE ARE HAPPY
WITH THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
IT WAS A VERY POWERFUL DECISION.
>> HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
DEMOCRATS VOWING TO KEEP LOOKING
FOR RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THE
INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD THE POWER TO
CALL WITNESSES.
>> THE REAL ACTION TURNS TO THE
SENATE WHERE TWO COMMITTEES
CONTINUE THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATIONS OF COLLUSION.
AT A PACE THAT HAS THE PARTIES
AT ODDS.
>> BLUNTLY THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
PAINFULLY AND GLACIALLY SLOW.
>> THE ONLY COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION APPEARS ANY AND
FROM THE HYPERPARTISAN INFLUENCE
OF THIS ELECTION YEAR IS ONE
BEING UNDERTAKEN BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AS VECTOR GENERAL.